bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 weekends
l'émission consacrée à vos loisirs et
vos idées de sortie alors au programme
du sport avec notre journaliste Anthony
Rech les expositions du moment où encore
du cinéma mais tout de suite place à
notre invité pour parler des soirées
spéciales Halloween
passage obligé des vacances de la
Toussaint Halloween avec ces citrouilles
et ses frayeurs s'invitent au château et
au parc de Thoiry des ce week-end pour
en parler avec nous en plateau Tiphaine
de la rivière bonjour vous êtes
animatrice culturelle du château de
Thoiry et alors les samedis 25 le
dimanche 26 et le lundi 27 octobre vous
proposez des soirées pour les enfants
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire un petit peu plus oui alors ça fera
déjà la sixième année qu'on propose ces
soirées pour les enfants donc ça
s'adresse plutôt à des enfants entre 6
et 12 ans qui sont la plupart du temps
accompagnés par leurs parents et c'est
un parcours qui dure environ deux heures
donc qui passe par les jardins de Thoiry
puisqu'on connaît évidemment le parc
animalier mais Thoiry c'est aussi
Desjardins un château et donc voilà tout
un parcours à la rencontre de
personnages d'Halloween et on terminera
donc au château par un petit goûter et
une petite collation alors apparemment
donc les enfants se transforme rond en
véritable petit aventurier à la
découverte des du parc et devront
parcourir des obstacles c'est qu'est-ce
que c'est ces obstacles alors c'est
c'est des épreuves en fait qui vont
devoir passer puisque voilà l'histoire
c'est qu'il y a un sortilège pour
pouvoir rentrer dans le château il va
falloir qu'ils trouvent l'incantation
magique à réciter devant le château et
pour trouver cette incantation ils vont
avoir à chaque fois des petites épreuves
donc par exemple les preuves phares
c'est de goûter à des insectes
évidemment les parents les parents
participent également et
alors des insectes évidemment
comestibles qu'on trouve ça peut être
des verres de farine des criquets ce
genre de petits animaux sympas
et donc à chaque fois il récolteront un
indice pour pouvoir rentrer au château à
la fin et ils peuvent également donc
pénétrer dans la forêt hantée qu'est-ce
que c'est cette forêt hantée
il y a aussi des grands espaces boisés à
Thoiry et donc là c'est vraiment le
cadre idéal on en profite la forêt il va
être rempli de personnages d'Halloween
donc des gnomes des ogres des bûcherons
mangeurs d'enfants qui vont qui vont
raconter leur histoire à chaque fois que
le groupe va passer les voir tout ça se
termine autour d'un d'une bonne soupe de
potiron c'est sympa
de soupe sont en préparation pour
pouvoir nourrir et récompenser tous les
petits monstres et évidemment les
traditionnelles bonbons d'Halloween qui
seront présents également ça demande
beaucoup de préparations je suppose une
soirée comme celle-ci c'est pas mal de
préparation et d'intervenants mais voilà
on commence à être bien rodé donc tout
se passe très bien d'accord si les
animateurs du château qui sont à une
équipe culturelle au château donc sur
tout l'équipe culturelle mais aussi des
gens du parc tout le monde met un petit
peu la main à la pâte donc c'est la
gouvernante du château qui prépare la
soupe ça va être des soigneurs
animaliers qui vont prendre part au rôle
aussi et jouer du coup les ogres et les
méchants de sorcières d'accord donc là
on a parlé des soirées qui auront lieu
donc ce week-end pour les enfants mais
la semaine prochaine vous proposez
également des soirées pour les adultes
donc ce sera le jeudi 30 et le vendredi
31 octobre on va peut-être en parler un
petit peu aussi alors cette fois ça sera
assez sous forme de jeu donc les gens
sont pas requis on conseille à partir de
14 ans du coup les gens viennent plutôt
entre amis ou entre en famille et là
pour le coup les sorcières seront un
petit peu moins gentils d'accord donc il
faut ça met de courage pour pouvoir
venir je pense qu'on aura le temps d'en
reparler d'ici là donc si vous n'avez
peur de rien n'hésitez pas il reste des
places je le rappelle donc c'est à
partir de 18h le samedi de 17h45 le
dimanche 26 et le lundi 27 octobre au
château et au parc de Thoiry le tarif
donc c'est 21 euros et pour les
détenteurs du Passeport Annuel 19 euros
pensées à réserver et donc pour les plus
grands ça se passe la semaine prochaine
on en reparlera merci Tiphaine de la
rivière d'être passé sur notre plateau
le départ se fait à 14h à la maison des
bonheurs de Magny-les-Hameaux
c'est la troisième édition le spectacle
et Castres pardon les nuits du haras au
Brévières proposent différents tableaux
et des numéros tous les plus
impressionnants les uns que les autres
la représentation a lieu tous les soirs
jusqu'à ce dimanche le 26 octobre nous
avons assisté au dernier répétitions
pour vous donner un petit avant-goût
Patrick Jacques
troisième édition des Nuits du haras au
bréviaire un spectacle son et lumière
avec une thématique cette année le
cinéma
par exemple Laurel et Hardy Mission
Impossible Star Wars
Moulin Rouge voilà chaque fois on essaie
de coller au thème du cinéma et les
spectacle c'est un
spectacle en plein développement ça
attire beaucoup en plus dans les
Yvelines on est département où il y a le
plus de licenciés en équitation donc les
gens qui aiment le cheval oui les
spectacle équestre oui ça se développe
beaucoup quatre soirées de
représentation avec comme invité
d'honneur celui que l'on présente comme
l'un des meilleurs dresseurs au monde
Jean-François pignon
avec ses chevaux il interviendra trois
fois dans le spectacle un travail tout
en finesse sans poésie presque en
silence un savoir-faire magique
vous vous l'avez vu Jean-François pignon
et donc l'invité d'honneur de ses nuits
du haras nous l'avons rencontré nous
parle de sa passion bien sûr mais aussi
de ses expériences au cinéma
nous sommes au rang national des
Bréviaires c'est ici que se dérouleront
les nuits du Haras du 23 au 26 octobre
et je suis en compagnie de l'invité
d'honneur Jean-François pignon bonjour
alors vous êtes l'un des plus grands
dresseurs de chevaux mondialement connu
c'est à l'âge de 12 ans qu'est né votre
passion lorsque donc votre père vous
achète une jument appelée gazelle la
vous louez une relation assez
particulière avec l'animal qu'est-ce qui
vous plaît dans ce rapport au cheval
c'est un rapport sans tradition avec
une méthode qui est venue après une
observation des chevaux entre eux et
puis
ce qui m'a vraiment plu à l'époque c'est
que mon père m'a en effet offert ce
cadeau mais il y avait aucune contrainte
ni de la part du cheval ni de la part de
mon père il m'a vraiment laissé la
liberté d'expression avec cette animal
de cette passion ensuite laisse des
spectacles des spectacles qui
rencontrent un réel succès parce que
justement vous avez une méthode assez
particulière de dressage en liberté
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
un peu sur cette méthode c'est très
simple en fait et c'est très logique
parce qu'en fait je me suis dit pour
parler
et être efficace avec un anglais autant
lui parler anglais et c'est exactement
la même chose avec les chevaux je me
suis dit je vais essayer de de
comprendre le langage cheval pour
essayer de parler cheval donc tout ce
qui est claquement de langue et chose
comme ça finalement moi je l'utilise pas
et j'essaie d'utiliser leur subtilité et
je dis bien j'essaye parce que je pense
que je serai toujours qu'un être humain
au milieu des chevaux mais ce que je
sais c'est que en m'appliquant à essayer
de respecter leur langage je me
rapproche d'eux et c'est ce que j'essaye
d'enseigner aussi au mieux
dans les années 2000 ensuite vous
entrez de première en 2016 dans le film
danse avec lui
alors danse avec lui c'est rigolo parce
qu'on est venu chercher dans un premier
temps comme dresseur de chevaux
uniquement et ce qui s'est passé c'est
que la réalisatrice qui est
très concentré sur la
gérer la véracité des images qu'elle
allait mettre dans ce film c'est dit que
l'idéal aurait été de boire pas
seulement en tant que dresseur mais
aussi dans le rôle du dresseur de
chevaux et en 2010 donc vous décidez de
poursuivre un peu l'aventure en
réalisant votre propre long-métrage il
s'appelle gazelle un nom pas choisi au
hasard parce qu'il s'agit de votre
première jument
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça raconte
ma vie tout simplement et
le film est intitulé gazelle parce que
je raconte tous les grands virages de ma
vie dans ce film j'ai pas retracé
40 ans de vie en
deux heures sans prendre le principal
simplement et gazelle étonnamment
finalement a plus de tous les grands
virages de ma ville notamment cette
possibilité de devenir artiste équestre
et d'en faire un vrai métier et
par la suite bien plus tard j'ai une
dizaine d'années plus tard elle m'a
aussi permis de croire en Dieu
aujourd'hui comment justement le fait de
croire en Dieu m'a amené à enfin je
dirais aimer les humains
d'ailleurs projeté dimanche soir
suite à la dernière représentation le 26
octobre il y aura ensuite un débat avec
vous merci Jean-François pignon de nous
avoir accordé un petit peu de temps
alors vous le savez donc le spectacle
l'inoui du haras c'est du 23 au 26
octobre ici au haras national des
Bréviaires
et à noter que les représentations du
vendredi 25 et samedi 26 octobre ont
lieu à 20h si elle lui dimanche 27 à 18h
pour les réservations n'hésitez pas à
vous rendre sur les sites Internet qui
s'affichent soit vous rendre directement
sur place tout de suite les rencontres
sportives du weekend
je vous le disais dans les titres notre
journaliste sportif Anthony Reis nous a
rejoint en plateau bonjour Anthony alors
quels sont les matchs à ne pas rater ce
week-end on commence avec du handball il
me semble oui la semaine passée les
féminines de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
après leur belle réaction une victoire
32 à 28 face au Paris Handball et bien
cette semaine elles peuvent continuer
cette belle remontée au classement et
elles ont l'occasion de poursuivre ce
mouvement dans cette poule de National 2
avec un challenge de taille ce week-end
puisque lors de la cinquième journée les
joueuses de Philippe l'étrange reçoivent
ni plus ni moins que le deuxième de la
poule Aubervilliers qui n'a subi à
écouter bien qu'un seul revers cette
saison c'était face à Lisieux lors de la
troisième journée de leur côté les
coéquipières de Gabriel parloir n'ont
pas réussi à enchaîner deux victoires
consécutives depuis le début de
l'exercice 2014 2015 c'est donc
l'occasion de confirmer les ambitions de
Bon Dieu de podium
commencer en début de saison par
l'entraîneur face à un concurrent direct
et vous allez le voir au classement le
classement va s'afficher et bien les
coéquipières de Gabriel parloir avant
cette 5e journée pointe à la cinquième
place avec 8 points Aubervilliers donc
deuxième et en cas de succès samedi soir
sur leur terrain avec des résultats
aussi favorables les inhymoine
pourraient faire un bon au classement et
passer devant Aubervilliers pour
assister évidemment à ce choc de la
cinquième journée rendez-vous au gymnase
Alain Colas c'est Alain Colas cette
semaine ce n'est pas le pire de
Coubertin en raison des vacances
scolaires à Montigny à 20h30 et on
continue avec du basket et le club
l'entente chez nez le Versailles qui
joue gros ce week-end
tout le club d'ailleurs et même tous les
supporters ont dû sûrement allumer un
cierge cette semaine pour voir la
première victoire de l'Entente le chêne
et Versailles ce week-end pour le compte
de la sixième journée de Nationale 3 de
basket les joueurs de Romain Dubosc
accueille le Mans une équipe que l'on
connaît bien notamment du côté de
frapper candidat à la montée autant dire
que les Yvelinois vont devoir réaliser
le match parfait pour espérer infliger
sa première défaite au club sartois Le
Mans est actuellement 3e avec 9 points
et le LCV toujours dans les bas-fonds de
cette poule et se retrouve à la 11e
place de ce classement général
provisoire les deux équipes il faut le
dire ne joue pas dans la même cour pour
l'instant cette saison annoncée comme
une saison un peu de transition par
l'entraîneur va vite devenir un vrai
parcours du combattant si les
versaillers ne se ressaisissent pas très
très vite et si vous souhaitez quand
même assister à la peut-être première
victoire de l'Entente Le Chesnay
Versailles en N3 cette année rendez-vous
au gymnase Montbauron à 20h ce samedi
soir on termine avec du foot oui trap
évidemment que que l'on suit de près
cette saison de Promotion d'Honneur trap
qui n'a plus gagné un match depuis un
mois et demi un peu plus d'un mois et
demi même et la première journée de
championnat face au pecs une victoire
trois business autant dire que la
réception ce dimanche de Parisis pour le
conte de la cinquième journée de
promotion d'honneur ressemble à une
opération commando les valdoisiens sont
la seule équipe encore invaincue de
cette poule D avec deux victoires et
deux nuls au compteur ce qui permet à
Parisi vous allez le voir de pointer au
troisième rang au classement général
avant cette rencontre avec 12 points
alors que trap se situe toujours en
milieu de tableau depuis quelques
semaines à la septième place avec 9
points 9 points en compteur en cas de
succès les Trappistes pourraient
recoller tout de même au podium de cette
poule de péage ou d'envoi à 15h ce
dimanche au stade Gilbert chancaciolet
merci Anthony pour toutes ces
informations on vous retrouve dès lundi
à 18h30 pour le satwisport place
maintenant à l'actualité cinéma
tout de suite les sorties ciné de la
semaine et les avis des spectateurs au
micro dès le dimanche
c'était sympa marrant c'est bien amusé
ça nous a plu c'est un bon dessin animé
je pensais que ça allait pas être
terrible par rapport aux images que j'ai
vu de la bande-annonce finalement
j'étais bien agréablement surpris et
c'était un très bon film c'est vraiment
très agréable la bande son est géniale
l'histoire est terrible c'est vraiment
vraiment super moment c'était une très
belle histoire une belle histoire
d'amour avec de l'action j'ai pleuré
j'ai rigolé c'était vraiment très bien
j'ai bien aimé
il y avait beaucoup d'actions et surtout
j'aime beaucoup les têtes de morts
j'ai trouvé ça charmant c'est une un
décor sympathique les acteurs jouent
bien ça a très beau film avec des très
très belles comédiennes elle
elles ont tout dans le comment dire dans
le ressenti dans le sens c'est très bien
c'est familial c'est amusant c'est c'est
joli c'est très joli il y a de beaux
paysages c'est un très bon film
c'est drôle il y a de l'émotion c'est
bien joué il faut regarder jusqu'au bout
faut écouter le générique la musique
parce qu'elle est super déjà et il faut
aller jusqu'au bout parce qu'il y a une
dernière image qui a à voir
cette semaine le coup de cœur de
l'espace Philippe Noiret et le film
s'emba réalisé par Eric Tolédano et
Olivier Nakache avec Omar Sy et
Charlotte Gainsbourg samba sénégalais en
France depuis 10 ans collectionne les
petits boulots alice est une cadre
supérieure épuisée par un burn out lui
essaye par tous les moyens d'obtenir ses
papiers alors quel temps de se
reconstruire par le bénévolat dans une
association chacun cherche à sortir de
son impasse jusqu'au jour où leur destin
vont se croiser
c'est ça j'ai passé aussi
ça se trouve pour lui c'est direct Dakar
et sans passer par les Duty Free a
carrément
je vais te donner un conseil faut garder
la distance parce qu'après ça peut
vraiment faire mal si ils sont envoyés
après avoir réussi dans intouchable leur
précédent film l'alchimie de l'humour et
de l'émotion pour parler du handicap des
deux réalisateurs trouvent la même
justesse de ton avec le thème des
sans-papiers et son cortège de
souffrance sans barre regorge de charme
de drôlerie et de moments dramatiques
intenses les deux réalisateurs négocient
parfaitement un virage plus grave avec
une élégance rare
qu'est-ce que tu fais là
terminé retourner travailler c'est fini
samba est à découvrir cette semaine à
l'espace Philippe Noiret
les expositions ne manquent pas non plus
dans les Yvelines ce week-end à
l'occasion des commémorations du
centenaire de la Première Guerre
mondiale la ville de Guyancourt a
souhaité donner une place au travail de
mémoire de certains artistes la
mezzanine de l'hôtel de ville présente
jusqu'au 6 novembre les œuvres de
François Mahieu Aurélia Debussy et
William elle le rencontrait
donner une place au travail de mémoire à
travers l'art dans le cadre des
commémorations du centenaire de la
Grande Guerre la mezzanine de l'Hôtel de
Ville Guyancourt accueille jusqu'au 6
novembre les œuvres de l'artiste
François maillot des sculptures créées à
partir de fragments
de bataille de la Première Guerre
mondiale homme du Billy depuis l'enfance
par la Grande Guerre François Mahieu
entame des recherches et très vite né le
besoin d'aller sur le terrain de
s'imprégner c'est ainsi qu'il croise le
chemin des Dames
j'étais comment dire
comme saisie par ce lieu je m'interdis
de de
faire toutefouille sur sur un terrain
sacré pendant ce serait et puis
c'est stigmates sont tellement présents
pour qu'ils veulent peu vous voulez voir
marcher regarder ramasser
que ressortent encore un siècle plus
tard les débris métalliques collectés
par l'artiste
je suis sensible à ce qui est je dirais
un peu déchiqueté brut ses éclats
à force de les manipuler j'ai voyais tu
voyais autre chose certains fragments je
le disais un morceau de torse je lisais
une tête et il met apparu une assemblée
évidente que j'allais travailler sur la
silhouette j'allais travailler sur des
corps redressés relever
abîmés mais debout de ces 15 années
consacrées à l'exploration du Chemin des
Dames l'artiste a également entrepris un
travail de peinture
toucher ému
bouleversé quand
j'arrive dans quand j'arrive de d'un
autre plateau que je vois cette ligne
d'horizon j'ai commencé à peindre sur
cet horizon
je ne suis pas dans la volonté de
comment dire de traduire des scènes des
scènes de guerre ou autre c'est vraiment
une interprétation
ressentie je quand je suis dans mon
atelier
cette exposition donne à saisir une
vision artistique de l'expérience de
guerre qui pour François Mahieu
s'inscrit dans une démarche d'éveil de
nos consciences
jusqu'au 2 novembre vous pouvez observer
des installations artistiques sur le
plateau de Limours deux artistes se sont
associés à 4 communes du Plateau et au
parc naturel de Chevreuse le but
interrogé sur le paysage mais surtout
sur la présence de l'eau claire Cambier
et William L
installez des œuvres d'art en plein
champ c'est le défi fou qu'on réalisait
Gilles Brousset et edwardsor sur le
plateau de Limours le parc naturel de la
vallée de Chevreuse et des agriculteurs
du coin souhaité valoriser le territoire
et révéler l'eau omniprésente discrète
et essentiel pour la culture du sol à
Gomez la ville on croit ses miroirs
comme des gouttes d'eau qui reflètent la
lumière comme les miroirs sont orientés
de façon à refléter le ciel on a une
équivalence entre l'arrière-plan du ciel
qui est à l'horizon et
le ciel qui est reflété dans les miroirs
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont tous alignés
avec la ligne d'horizon
et que on a un effet de descente du ciel
sur la terre en petite gouttes d'où le
nom de la sculpture l'eau qui tombe on
peut aller se balader
on s'approchant la vision de l'oeuvre
change de regard et jeux d'optique
chacun des miroirs et une sorte
d'échantillon des couleurs et des
lumières du ciel comme une palette ça
donne
si vous voyez les miroirs il y a
peut-être
100 miroirs ça fait sans nuances de gris
en choisissant un miroir une fenêtre sur
le ciel on observe un paysage différent
et pourtant bien familier ce fameux
miroir il faut se
les imaginer devant ce beau plateau
agricole et puis le reflet qui peuvent
amener tout autour on voulait essayer de
comme on dit de trouver une coordination
entre les ruraux et les citadins en tout
cas preuve ont pris place sur le plateau
toute reprenne le miroir comme support
mais le véritable matériau de l'oeuvre
reste le ciel le reflet qu'il renvoie à
bouler les trous on retrouve l'eau qui
court ces miroirs suivent les
inclinaisons de ce fossé de récupération
des eaux usées
c'est pour expliquer quand même l'eau le
rôle de l'eau avec l'agriculture je
pense qu'elle s'intéresse beaucoup plus
à l'agriculture qui a quelques années
peut-être
je pense que les personnes sont beaucoup
plus sensibilisées dans ce domaine-là un
rôle pédagogique de sensibilisation qui
peut intriguer des habitants pour mieux
saisir ses œuvres des visites
explicatives et des balades sont
organisées jusqu'au 2 novembre Edouard
sort s'occupe de photographie les œuvres
et les ateliers ils souhaiterait faire
vivre ce projet au-delà de ses
installations sur ces territoires on
voit des champs on voit du ciel mais
l'eau on la devine que rarement d'autant
plus que sur le plateau elle est
invisible donc un des enjeux a été de
rendre cette eau visible les œuvres ils
sont pour quelque chose la carte devra
le faire aussi cette carte c'est la
carte du plateau de l'immo dans ce livre
des éléments relatifs aux oeuvres des
photos du making of mais aussi des
explications sur l'eau et le plateau et
des rencontres avec les agriculteurs et
les habitants de forme carrée pour
s'effeuiller pour constituer une carte
complète du territoire pour le financer
il fait appel aux particuliers via un
site participatif avis aux amateurs
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis prochain rendez-vous
avec l'actualité dès 18h avec Wilfried
Richie d'ici là je vous souhaite un
excellent weekend